So the simplest form of predication
supporting hardware will be a conditional move
instruction. In the MIPS instruction set, for
example, there is a MOVZ instruction that
takes two sources and the destination register. And the way this works is that
this instructor compares Rt to 0. And if it is 0, then changes
Rd to be equal to Rs, otherwise leaves Rd alone. Note that there is no branch
here anymore because this is a single instruction.
MIPS also has a MOVN instruction that works
exactly the same way, except it moves Rs into Rd only if Rt is not 0. So, we
would implement our x equals depending on condition x1 or x2 by doing something
like using comparisons or whatever, to put the result of the condition into,
let's say, R3. Then R1 would be our whatever x1 expression we wanted
to implement. R2 would be our x2. And then we will do,
MOVN x, R1, R3. MOVZ
X, R2, R3. And this puts
one of these two into X, depending on whether R3 was true or false. Which means,
depending on the condition. The x86 instruction set has a whole
set of so called CMOV instructions, so for example it has
CMOVZ, CMOVNZ, CMOV greater than etc, where the condition here is determined by
the flags. And all of these instructions
effectively implement the, if the condition codes
correspond to one of these conditions, depending
on the instruction, then the destination register
gets the value of the source register,
otherwise the destination register is not modified.
So, you can see how we can implement similar behavior here.
Except maybe we don't even need to put the condition in
a register because, probably we can just test the condition and
then, do a greater than, less than and so on on it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]